I had a horrible dream last night now
one of those it'll wake up in a cold
sweat types the calendar read Wednesday
November 7th and the Democrats had
gained control of the House of
Representatives and the the first like
horrible vision I had is kind of blurry
but it was Maxine Waters and she was
talking about justice Cavanaugh it was
heartbreaking
but I think women are not going to
recede women are going to continue to
confront what took place in that
confirmation and him and he won't rest
easy in his job Oh Maxine mean by that
he won't rest easy it kinda sounds like
an implicit threat to me or does she
just mean impeachment or that the
Justice is gonna be confronted at his
home and public life public places is it
some kind of dog whistle to go after
Cavanaugh similar to her earlier call to
harass conservatives earlier this year
well soon
she may be harassing all of America if
the Democrats wrest control of the House
of Representatives guess what
auntie em could be the first woman to
lead the House Financial Services
Committee now never mind that she once
faced three ethics violations charges
for setting up a meeting between
Treasury officials and a bank her hubby
sat on the board of and had large
investments in but Maxine thinks she's
Teflon so she just keeps on making
threats I'm gonna keep saying that we
need to impeach him join with me if he
thinks he can stop me from talking about
impeach forty five he's got another
thought coming
[Applause]
and beach party by that's my ringtone by
the way it's so I always want to avoid
it and this is another man who shares
Maxine's impeachment fantasy if the
Democrats weep to power Jerry Nadler
would become chairman of the Judiciary
Committee
he's already sharpening his knife or or
fork a knife for Cavanaugh we would have
to investigate any credible allegations
certainly of perjury and other things
that haven't been properly looked into
before if he is on the Supreme Court and
and the Senate hasn't investigated that
night then the house will have to now
with all that's facing America all our
potential do we really want a prolonged
Inquisition of a sitting Supreme Court
justice the last and only time the house
impeach the Supreme Court justice was in
1804 so you are you ready for Cavanaugh
circus part three well unless senator
Spartacus becomes a lion-tamer I'm gonna
pass on that three ringer
then there's Massachusetts congressman
Richie Neal he's poised to become the
chairman of the House Ways and Means
Committee and if that happens forget the
idea of making those Trump middle-class
tax cuts permanent Neal was a fierce
opponent of the Trump tax package and is
expected to try to roll back some of
those tax cuts there goes our economic
boom and then there's Maryland Elijah
Cummings he's in line to become chairman
of the Oversight and Government Reform
Committee his mission to investigate the
Trump administration's seven ways to
Sunday I want to look at what President
Trump has done aided and abetted by the
Republicans in Congress to tear down the
foundations of our democracy that's all
well Cummings is already on record as
saying he'd like to probe Trump's
cancellation of security clearances the
2020 census the rights of federal
employees and the president's treatment
of the press
now this frivolous partisan
investigations would cost millions and
of course achieve Zippo but they would
certainly serve the Democrats goal of
paralyzing the president and his
administration in a blizzard of probes
and inquiries and my friends it won't
end there
if Peter DeFazio becomes a
Transportation Committee Chairman he's
planning to do oversight of the Trump
International Hotel and the Government
Services Administration which is the
agency that gave Trump a lease for the
old post office building in DC where the
hotel is and if money is power
congresswoman Nita Lowey
of New York is about to become the queen
of the house she could head the powerful
appropriations committee in charge of
spending your money
Loie has never met a liberal social
program she didn't like and the 81 year
old Democrat would have the power to
shift our sprinting spending priorities
from things like defense and border
security to welfare and arts programs
that'll keep the economy humming and the
wall it'll never be funded the left is
salivating over all of these
possibilities in a liberal house
takeover Adam Schiff could restart the
Russia investigation Elijah Cummings
that oversight will have subpoena power
you know Maxine Waters will be the head
of the Committee on financial regulation
you're just you know the House Ways and
Means Committee will be able to obtain
Trump's tax returns it's gonna be a
completely different environment in
terms of the ability to hold them
accountable for all these outrages for
the MSNBC crowd it's like Christmas
morning but for America it would be the
nightmare we cannot allow to become a
reality if this band of liberal misfits
and radicals takes the reins of power in
the house come November
it'll be scarier than Halloween only the
trick will be on the American people and
the treats they'll be given away to
someone else and that's the angle